we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a caller who
doesn't like that we have advertisers
and is asking why we have advertisers
let's listen
hey David I'm just wondering why you
dedicate five to ten minutes of every
show to your sponsors and trying to sell
stuff I just think it takes away from
the overall message and it makes you
achieve
um listen
um so we have advertisers because they
generate revenue for the show and that's
why just about any successful show has
advertisers
um I listen to you know Cal newport's
podcast I listen to podcasts from
Argentina I listen to you well they they
all have advertisers and mostly it's the
same reason it's to generate revenue for
the show our hour show does have about
four minutes of ads in it on average
um it's a lot less than commercial you
know commercial TV might have 39 minutes
of content and 21 minutes of ads 17
minutes of ads sometimes we have a lot
less than that but the reason we have
advertisers is uh to fund the work that
we do now
um as I've said before we estimate
around one percent not even probably
more like three quarters of one percent
of our total audience
supports us with memberships on our
website around three quarters of one
percent if we were able to grow our
direct support from that three quarters
of one percent up to like two percent of
our audience supporting us directly then
we could do away with all of the
advertising on any platform on every
platform we're not there at this point
in time and so the reason that there are
advertisers is to generate revenue and I
think you'll find that that's relatively
uncontroversial we have such a great
bonus show for you today oh the bonus
everybody else
why do we make money on the bonus show
to generate Revenue okay more people are
getting away with murder in the sense
that unsolved killings have reached a
record high we're going to talk about it
number two
federal prisons want inmates to pay
their victims before being allowed to
make phone calls or even buy shoes in
prison
what we will discuss and lastly there is
a sperm donor who has fathered 550
children who has been told it's time to
stop the reason why may surprise you
although it may not all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show sign up
at joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get a tidy little
discount I'll see you then and we'll
have a brand new show for you tomorrow